for the first time we are seeing
dramatic video showing an astonishing
rescue after an avalanche buried two
women you can see the rescuers rushed to
dig the first one out as she frantically
pleads for help it happened last month
and a ski resort in the Swiss Alps
winter is the peak time for avalanches
there and so far this season 16
Americans have died in snow slides here
in the United States Charlie d'Agata has
more on the rescue and the devices that
help save both women's lives fighting
back panic while fighting for air a
British snowboarder buried in an
avalanche in Verbier Switzerland late
last month so a massive avalanche going
down the next door space professional
snowboarder Victor leaving gute could
see the disaster that was about to
unfold and fortunately two girls were
snowboarding in the middle of that they
say they didn't saw the Avalanche coming
I assume and so the avalanche hit them
from the back he and his fellow
snowboarders raced to their rescue what
do you do in a situation like that
you've got professional training you
should have always with you like a
beacon a shovel a probe and ABS backpack
like an air bag backpack and those tools
are like super useful in case you were
getting coated in another landfill in
case you need to search from one foot by
an avalanche a ripcord inflates that
orange air bag which helps lift victims
up from the snow reducing the risk of
being buried and suffocating how
important was it for these two young
women to have those tools on them I
would say that without those tools the
two woman's will not be there today
they've already saved two people's lives
now they're hoping the message they're
trying to spread may save many more for
CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata London
you don't think about this but 16
Americans died this year
in avalanches it's a bigger number than
I would've thought yeah me too must have
been such a helpless feeling but you had
to feel good knowing people were there
working live right and imagine what it's
like to be buried under snow this is
terrifying